à cannes les festivaliers sont partis il
ne reste que le palmarès et les palmes
que nous vous rappelons dans ses grandes
lignes le week end
ah ça c'est sûr une palme d'or pour un
second film il y a de quoi être vraiment
tout est mis au point même de se laisser
aller face à certaines rancoeurs à des
gestes moyennement ce portrait
mais qu'apporte le dépit le palmarès est
dit est le 47e du nom avait au moins le
mérite de l'inattendu à l'image du film
de quang ninh tarantino pulp fiction
l'on retrouvera entre autres le plus
fameux tombeur dominé du samedi soir en
porte flingues déjanté surprise encore
avec les larmes de la reine virna lisi
sacrée meilleure interprète féminine
devant toutes les princesses entre pas
non c'est pour son rôle dans la reine
margot également prix du jury de fait le
cinéma français afficher cette fois une
grosse grosse forme avec la caméra d'or
pour pascale ferran mais aussi le prix
du meilleur scénario pour l'acteur
auteur réalisateur qui désormais marche
en pleine lumière
j'ai eu l'occasion dé déjà prêt content
ici en 86 ch pensé que c'était le plus
beau jour de ma carrière je me suis
trompé pas beaucoup et pourquoi parler
trop vite
le jury ne s'y est pas trompé non plus
moins surprenant peut-être mais sûrement
pas moins mérité le grand prix du jury
est passé à l'est pour le russe nikita
mikhalkov et son soleil trompeur et pour
le chinois zhang yimou et sont finement
forme d'appel vivre également récompensé
à travers son interprète principal gaye
ou ce qui ne changera jamais non plus et
l'émotion des lauréats surpris jusque
dans leur journal intime par
l'acclamation de tant de spectateurs
clint eastwood est pas exact une
dernière image celle d'un président du
jury qui était semble-t-il
définitivement plus à l'aise dans le
maniement du 357 magnum que l'on celui
de la langue de molière